this is Toyota's new crossover SUV the C
HR with its futuristic look it's an
instant stand out among the brands
generally unspectacular range it's
available in three versions we took the
style selection variant for a spin car
testa undelete zimmelman points out that
this model was rolled out from initial
design to volume production in less than
three years CHR stands for coupe a high
rider
it was slated for release under Toyotas
North American sub brand scion but with
science demise Toyota gave it a brand
new name for worldwide distribution met
veidt's the [ __ ] Ivan well its angular
lines in brawny front the CHR undeniably
radiates sheer power the many corners in
its silhouette disguised the compact
length of four point three meters the
fenders also suit the young design
the backseat door handles are elegantly
integrated into the c-pillar just
beneath the roofline the outward
protruding taillights lend the car a
modern self-confident appearance
[Music]
endogenous EHR andre says is available
in germany with either a 1.2 liter
turbocharged four-cylinder engine or a
hybrid engine for three thousand euros
extra the approximately 110 kilowatt 2
liter engine is only available in the US
but Andre regrets that neither the
American nor the German market CHR is
equipped with a really powerful
turbocharged engine taking ten point
nine seconds to accelerate from zero to
100 kilometers an hour the Toyota CHR
isn't as sporty as it looks though
sluggish it scores points for low fuel
consumption at just 6 liters per 100
kilometers it's suitable for longer
journeys
[Music]
I just miss Andre remarks he was
astounded by how good the CH arse
interior looks the lacquered components
really make it smart often guns and
Helvetica it's Nouveau and these
imitation seams of course this is a
really sewn leather but it looks really
great Optus office there's a good the
only thing he criticizes are the sat-nav
software and graphics which he thinks
look a bit outdated
so nine bits in hangar got our test car
has a heated steering wheel
the gauges match the rest of the
futuristic interior the central console
is tidy but about the only place to stow
things is in the doors the color of the
seats matches the dashboard their lower
back support makes them very comfortable
then 105 Andre says that there are
various ways of breaking when
approaching a curve or a traffic light
giving us the vex study one is to shift
down and let the transmission slow the
car but that jolts the car making it out
of balance and putting we're on the
mechanical parts get off the Technic or
if you're an experienced driver you can
double clutch but it's not so easy to
find the perfect pressure points at the
same time on all three pedals its
affinity that sitting at these to your
target dot that's why I tell you to
install the IMT system a fancy name for
an automatic double clutching system
when you shift down the car
automatically uses targeted fuel bursts
to adjust the revs between the
transmission and the engine so that the
car uses the engine braking effect
without jerking or wear and tear or a
mere four Slice before Tyler the Moto
grams become Watson can the Toyota CHR
went on sale in January 2017 in Germany
starting at about 22 thousand euros
[Music]
Andre says the CHR is a good car of
course but he would have preferred it
without the unnecessarily high ground
clearance and with a bigger sporty-er
engine he thinks this design would fit a
sporty compact whether an SUV needs such
an aggressive design is another question
that's a matter hinder stairs